patrick stewart
let's do it
nightcrawler yeah you're gross
when you teleport it smells very bad you
just cropped us the whole team
do you know angela lansbury yes of
course she's one of my favorites
mark
you look like whale diarrhea you look
like you hung out on the set of a porno
all day where unwashed men and women
were grinding in a hot tub filled with
recycled lube
you getting this yeah that is a joke
that i do understand
i feel like if camp children
said moist six times into a mirror you
would appear
what is this
mirror three times it's a film called
candy man candy munchbuilder
what is the reference to
candyman yeah candy munchbuilder
all the kinders look into the room and
say kinder munchbuilder candy
munchbuilder candy munch below
candymanship
and he comes out and gives them treats
i don't know what movie you're
referencing
probably in some theater where people
can still smoke and there's a donkey
playing the piano
villain australia
what is the problem professor you are
focusing merely on my moistness
professor you established this mansion
as a haven for us mutants
that is a fair point
b mark
what i'm saying is you're gross
and you are fine thank you
and you're fired i understand
good day
i love it it's making me sad
like i want you to kind of deserve it
because you're an idiot
right now i just feel like a big bully
i bid you a good day professor
there's
sweat dripping from my fake bald head
now who is the moist one